okay it's time to shut the whole thing
down says a quart about Donald Trump's
Charitable Foundation a court is going
to be supervising the total and complete
shutdown of the Trump Foundation which
is Trump's quote charity which has been
conducting all sorts of illegal business
and has served effectively as a personal
slush fund for Donald Trump to buy
politicians and to buy paintings of
himself for his golf clubs as crazy as
that sounds and an agreement has been
reached which will mandate that Trump
fully shut down his personal charity
give away the remaining money to a group
of approved charities as part of the
agreement and this is all because of the
quote persistent illegal conduct that it
and Trump have participated in through
this charitable foundation this is
connected to the presidential campaign
because one of the illegal things that
the charitable foundation did was
coordinate between Trump's personal
charity and the 2016 presidential
campaign including the promises of
financial contributions from the charity
at campaign events meant to curry favor
for Trump with special interest groups
including veterans including donations
that were never ultimately given it
includes repeated self-dealing
by trumps foundation not only did Trump
use the money which remember was donated
to the foundation on the basis of being
charitable contributions for actual
charities and nonprofits they use the
money to pay legal settlements for
Trump's private businesses they use the
money to buy art for Donald Trump's golf
clubs and they use the money to make
banned political contributions including
to Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi
right around the time that Pam Bondi
decided that actually Florida was not
going to investigate the Trump found a
trump university rather Trump tried
closing the foundation in 2016 when it
was clear that they were in trouble but
the New York Attorney General said no no
no
we're now investigating and you need to
allow us to do that even if you're not
going to be an active foundation going
forward of course one of Donald Trump's
lawyers is saying that this is all
merely political but the truth is that
this is part of the rampant systematic
criminality of the Trump enterprises and
this includes the presidential campaign
this includes Trump's private businesses
and this now includes Trump's Charitable
Foundation so think about that for a
second Pat Trump's private businesses
have at minimum participated in the
employment of undocumented immigrants
and are suspected of helping to launder
money for Russians and Saudis through
real estate deals Trump's presidential
campaign was involved at minimum in
felonious payoffs to ex mistresses
directed by Donald Trump
through his attorney Michael Cohen and
there's clearly a hell of a lot more
coming when it comes to the presidential
campaign and then now we have Trump's
Charitable Foundation which has been
making donations which has been using
donated money as slush funds and for
illegal political donations on Monday I
did a story something along the lines of
every aspect of Donald Trump's world
involves criminality personal campaign
charitable etc can you think of any
aspect Pat of Trump's life at this point
that is not allegedly criminal the one
thing that you would think wouldn't be
criminal would be a charitable
foundation but Trump finds a way and I
remember during the 2016 presidential
election there was much to do about the
Clinton Foundation and criminality there
well which foundation is now being
investigated which one has to be shut
down
it's the Trump Foundation and it looks
like they're gonna have to find another
way to commission those $20,000
portraits of him and by those Tim Tebow
helmets because this is no longer going
to be the right vehicle to do so it's
all coming back right it's all Retro
actively being exposed as projection
Hillary's emails well Trump is spilling
secrets to a Russian spy recruiter half
of trumps staff is
using personal email including Jared
Kushner and Ivanka and the whole lot of
them when it comes to attacks on the
Clinton Foundation it turns out that
actually it's the Trump foundation
that's being forced to shut down because
of rampant rampant criminality it's all
projection and it always has been and
it's now being exposed to such piece by
piece by piece and consider just for a
moment this is what I was thinking about
last night
if trumpet never run for president he'd
be getting away with his criminal
business and his criminal charity his
kids wouldn't be under investigation and
at risk of indictment his business
partners and inner circle members
wouldn't be under investigation some
already convicted some of them headed to
or already in prison his entire legacy
wouldn't be under the microscope and
meanwhile there's a bombshell buried in
the report about Trump's charitable
foundation shutting down which is that
this isn't the end even though the
organization the foundation is shutting
down the lawsuit against the charity by
the New York AG will continue and the
investigation of Donald Trump and his
three oldest children and their
involvement in the running of this
criminal Charitable Foundation that's
going to continue and of course the kids
are directly implicated not surprising
but very very interesting and 2019 is
shaping up to be just absolutely crazy
make sure to follow the david pakman
show on instagram at david pakman show
rejected voicemails that don't make it
onto the broadcast show are available
there behind the scenes pictures are
available there what else
early hatred mail previews top YouTube
comments of the week featured on the
David Pakman show Instagram follow us
there at David Pakman show and while
you're at it follow me at David Pakman
on Instagram as well one of today's
sponsors is Skillshare which is an
incredible online learning community
offering over 10,000 high-quality online
courses on a huge variety of topics
first 500 who click the link under this
video we'll get to
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you just
took a really great class on graphic
design which I know nothing about but
I'm trying to learn our show is giving
you two entire months of totally free
access to every course Skillshare offers
risk free if you click the link under
this video you'll have two months to
take classes on anything you're
passionate about classes taught by real
people who share that passion and after
that you can keep getting access to the
entire site for less than 10 bucks a
month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share but hurry it's only available to
the first 500 who sign up